whether you like it or not radical
transparency and algorithmic
decision-making is coming at you fast
and it's going to change your life
that's because it's now easy to take
algorithms and embed them into computers
and gather all that data that you're
leaving on yourself all over the place
and know what you're like and then
direct the computers to interact with
you in ways that are better than most
people can
well that might sound scary I've been
doing this for a long time and I have
found it to be wonderful
my objective has been to have meaningful
work and meaningful relationships with
the people I work with and I've learned
that I couldn't have that unless I had
that radical transparency and that
algorithmic decision that game I want to
show you why that is I want to show you
how it works and I warn you that some of
the things that I'm going to show you
probably are a little bit shocking since
I was a kid I've had a terrible rote
memory and I didn't like following
instructions I was no good at following
instructions but I'd love to figure out
how things work for myself when I was 12
I hated school but I fell in love with
trading the markets I can't eat at the
time earned about five dollars a bag and
I took my counting money and I put it in
the stock market and that was just
because the stock market was hot at the
time and the first company I bought was
a company by the name of Northeast
Airlines Northeast Airlines was the only
company I heard of that was selling for
less than five dollars a share and I
figured I could buy more shares and if
we went up I'd make more money so there
was a dumb strategy right but I tripled
my money I tripled my money because I
got lucky the company was about to go
bankrupt but some other company acquired
it and I tripled my money and I was
hooked and I thought this game is easy
with time I learned this game is
anything but easy in order to be an
effective investor one has to bet
against the consensus and be right and
it's not easy to bet against the
census and be right when has the bet
against the consensus and be right
because the consensus is built into the
price and in order to be an entrepreneur
a successful entrepreneur one has to bet
against the consensus and be right I had
to be an entrepreneur and an investor
and what goes along with that is making
a lot of painful mistakes so I made a
lot of painful mistakes and with time my
attitude about those mistakes began to
change I began to think of them as
puzzles that if I could solve the
puzzles they would give me gems and the
puzzles were what would I do differently
in the future so I wouldn't make that
painful mistake and the gems were
principles that I would then write down
so I would remember them that would help
me in the future and because I wrote
them down so clearly I could then
eventually discovered I could then embed
them into algorithms and those
algorithms would be embedded in
computers and the computers would make
decisions along with me and so in
parallel we would make these decisions
and I could see how those decisions then
compared with my own decisions and I
could see that those decisions were a
lot better and that was because the
computer could make decision decisions
much faster it could process a lot more
information and it can process decisions
much more less emotionally so it
radically improved my decision-making
eight years after I started Bridgewater
I had my greatest failure my greatest
mistake it was um it was late 1970s I
was 34 years old and I had calculated
that American banks had lent much more
money to emerging countries than those
countries were going to be able to pay
back and that we would have the greatest
debt crisis since the Great Depression
and with it an economic crisis and a big
bear market in stocks it was a
controversy
view at the time people thought it was
kind of a crazy point of view but in
August 1982 Mexico defaulted on its debt
and a number of other countries followed
and we had the greatest debt crisis
since the Great Depression and because I
had anticipated that I was asked to
testify to Congress and appear on Wall
Street week which was the show of the
time just to give you a flavor for that
I've got a clip here and you'll see me
in there mr. chairman mr. Mitchell it's
a great pleasure and a great honor to be
able to appear before you and
examination with what is going wrong
with our economy the economy is now flat
teetering on the brink of failure you
were recently quoted in an article you
said I can say this with absolute
certainty because I know how markets
work I can say with absolute certainty
that if you look at the liquidity base
in the corporation's and the world as a
whole but there's such a reduced level
of liquidity that you can't return to an
era of stagflation I look at that now I
think what an arrogant jerk I was so
arrogant and I was so wrong I mean while
the debt crisis happened the stock
market and the economy went up rather
than going down and I lost so much money
from my for myself and for my clients
that I had to shut down my operation
pretty much I had to let almost
everybody go and these were like
extended family and it was heartbroken
and I had lost so much money that I had
to borrow $4,000 from my dad to help to
pay my family bills it was one of the
most painful experiences of my life but
it turned out to be one of the greatest
experience of my life because it changed
my attitude about decision-making rather
than thinking I'm right
I started asked myself how do I know I'm
right
I gained a humility that I needed in
order to balance with my audacity I
wanted to find the smartest people who
would disagree with me to try to
understand their perspective or
have them stress test my perspective I
wanted to make an idea meritocracy in
other words not an autocracy in which I
would lead and others would follow and
not a democracy in which everybody's
points of view were equally valued but I
wanted have an idea meritocracy in which
the best ideas would win out and in
order to do that I realized that we
would need radical truthfulness and
radical transparency what I mean by
radical truthfulness and radical
transparency is people needed to say
what they really believed and to see
everything and we literally tape almost
all conversations and let everybody see
everything because if we didn't do that
we couldn't really have an idea merit to
crap meritocracy in order to have a idea
of meritocracy we have to let people
speak and say what they want just to
give you an example this is an email
from Jim Haskell who somebody works with
me and this was available to everybody
in the company ray you have deserve a
d-minus for your performance today in
the meeting you did not prepare it all
well because there was no way you could
have been that disorganized isn't that
great that's great it's great because
first of all I needed feedback like that
I need feedback like that and it's great
because if I don't let Jim and people
like Jim to express their points of view
our relationship wouldn't be the same
and if I didn't make that public for
everybody to see we wouldn't have an
idea of meritocracy so for the last 25
years that's how we've been operating
we've been operating with this radical
transparency and then collecting these
principles largely from making mistakes
and then embedding those principles into
algorithms and then those algorithms
provide were following the algorithms in
parallel with our thinking that has been
how we've run the investment business
and it's how we also deal with the
people management in order to give you a
glimmer into what this looks like I'd
like to take you into a meeting and
introduce you to a tool of ours called
the
collector that helps us do this a week
after the US election our research team
held a meeting to discuss what a trump
presidency would mean for the US economy
naturally people have different opinions
on the matter and how we were
approaching the discussion the dot
collector collects these views it has a
list of a few dozen attributes so
whenever somebody thinks something about
another person's thinking it's easy for
them to convey their assessment they
simply note that attribute and provider
rating from 1 to 10 for example as the
meeting began a researcher named Jen
rated me a three in other words badly
for not showing a good balance of
open-mindedness and assertiveness as the
meeting transpired Jen's assessments of
people added up like this others in the
room have different opinions that's
normal
different people are always going to
have different opinions and who knows
who's right let's look at just what
people thought about how I was doing
some people thought I did well others
poorly with each of these views we can
explore the thinking behind the numbers
here's what Jen and Larry said note that
everyone gets to express their thinking
including their critical thinking
regardless of their position in the
company Jen who's 24 years old and right
out of college can tell me the CEO that
I'm approaching things terribly this
tool helps people both express their
opinions and then separate themselves
from their opinions to see things from a
higher level when Jen and others shift
their attentions from inputting their
own opinions - looking down on the whole
screen their perspective changes they
see their own opinions as just one of
many and naturally start asking
themselves how do I know my opinion is
right that shift in perspective is like
going from seeing in one dimension to
seeing in multiple dimension
and it shifts the conversation from
arguing over our opinions to figuring
out objective criteria for determining
which opinions are best behind the dot
collector is a computer that is watching
and watches what all these people are
thinking and it correlates that with how
they think and it communicates advice
back to each of them based on that then
it draws the data from all the meetings
to create a pointillist painting of what
people are like and how they think and
it does that guided by algorithms
knowing what people are like helps to
match them better with their jobs for
example a creative thinker who was
unreliable might be matched up with
someone who's reliable but not creative
knowing what people are like also allows
us to decide what responsibilities to
give them and to weigh our decisions
based on people's merits we call it
their believability here's an example of
a vote that we took where the majority
of people felt one way but when we
weighed the views based on people's
merits the answer was completely
different this process allows us to make
decisions not based on democracy not
based on autocracy but based on
algorithms that take people's
believability into consideration yeah we
frequently do this
we do it because it eliminates what I
believe to be one of the greatest
strategies of mankind and that is people
arrogantly naively holding in opinions
in their minds that are wrong and acting
on them and not putting them out there
to stress test them and that's a tragedy
and we do it because it elevates
ourselves above our own opinions so that
we start to see things through
everybody's eyes and we see things
collectively collective decision-making
is so much better than individual
decision-making if it's done well it's
been the secret sauce behind our success
it's why we've made more money for our
clients than any other hedge fund in
existence and made money 23 out of the
last 26 years so what's the problem with
being radically truthful and radically
transparent with each other people say
it's emotionally difficult critics say
it's a formula for a brutal work
environment neuroscientists tell me it
has to do with our our brains are
pre-wired there's a part of our brain
that would like to know our mistakes and
like to look at our weaknesses so we
could do better I'm told that that's the
prefrontal cortex and then there's a
part of our brain which views all of
this as attacks
so until that that's the amygdala in
other words there are two use inside you
there's an emotional you and there's an
intellectual you and often they're at
odds and often they work against you
it's been our experience that we can win
this battle we win it as a group it
takes about 18 months typically to find
that most people prefer operating this
way with this radical transparency than
to be operating in a more opaque
environment there's not politics there's
not the brutality of you know all of
that hidden behind the scenes there's an
idea meritocracy where people can speak
up and that's been great it's given us
more effective work and it's given us
more effective relationships
but it's not for everybody we found
something like 25 or 30 percent of the
population it's just not for and by the
way when I say radical transparency I'm
not saying transparency about everything
I mean you don't have to tell somebody
that their walls 5 is growing or their
baby's ugly so you
I'm just looking about talking about the
important things so so when you leave
this room I'd like you to observe
yourself in conversations with others
imagine if you knew what they were
really thinking and imagine if you knew
what they were really like and imagine
if they knew what you were really
thinking and what you were really like
it would certainly clear things up a lot
and make your operations together more
effective I think it'll improve your
relationships now imagine that you can
have algorithms that will help you
gather all that information and even
help you make decisions on I did in an
idea meritocratic way this sort of
radical transparency is coming at you
and it is going to affect your life and
in my opinion it's going to be wonderful
so I hope it is as wonderful for you as
it is for me thank you very much
[Applause]